this
is uh we got a colombian a venezuelan a
mechagon
okay now we're live we are live
officially okay so we are live
at by the way fyi everybody just so you
know
adam is on fire fired up fired up we got
tom zenner here yeah no
that's too much pressure that's too much
yeah he's on fire today just so you know
tom good to have you on nice to see you
guys
great office happy to be here i got to
credit you guys man you know you heard
all these stories about the people
leaving new york
and california for florida and for texas
you guys were smart enough to leave
texas for florida i mean time to
talk about timing with the weather right
now i don't know oh buddy it's it's uh
it's uh it's pretty intense i mean we
lived there for i lived there for five
years and we never had
negative it they say it feels like it's
negative 10 right now in dallas
yeah no electricity none of everybody's
worn five
layers of clothes it's it's a mess
colder in dallas yesterday
at when the sun rose five degrees as
opposed to anchorage alaska where it was
18. that is that's how bad it is that is
intense and you know what's crazy yeah
yesterday tom ellsworth still figured
out a way to get out of the airport he
drove to the airport 35 miles an hour
got on a flight set the example for
morale to follow they got on a flight
they head to louisville
for an event with sepals vargas and the
rest of the crew so you know
shout out to them yeah tebow's going to
be there and thibaut's apparently going
to be a baseball player right now
apparently you know
touchdown jesus goes to home run jesus
you're your favorite guy you're you're a
big teenager that's your
tebow guys yeah yeah so anyways we got
we got a lot of things to cover today
and a lot of these things because we're
clear the last time that we all did this
we were in dallas six weeks ago what are
the chances why we all go back to dallas
and do this
let's stay in boca that's what i don't
think it's gonna happen fired up yeah so
so tell us
why you're lit up today what is it is it
coffee is it the seven minute bike ride
is it the workout is it the shorts what
what happened
it's everything it's everything and much
more by the way
adam showed up with the most on up you
look how do you
how do you explain those shorts you know
how you watch people wearing shorts and
then there's uncomfortable shorts where
they're three inches too high shorts
yeah yeah what's up with what's the
shorts
they're called daisy dukes i think it's
one of those things that can't be
explained it has to be experienced
yeah you don't want to experience you
know the real atoms coming out now that
we're in florida yeah we're going to
learn a lot he's a little bit more
comfortable i started rollerblading to
work just
alert my parents can you tell us real
quick what happened i rode my bike to
work
what happened with the donut today oh
there's donuts donuts don't disrespect
it was a muffin
oh muffin it was a big difference listen
kai's gonna weigh in here kai can you
turn me up on the audio here
turn kai down a little bit 20 and turn
me up 10
cause i'm fired up uh last night we had
an hr situation going on here our first
hr situation in the office so here's
what happened i'm gonna play this out
real quick we'll get to the podcast kai
huge carb advocate huge carb advocate he
eats carbs like he's never gonna be
donuts muffins wraps sandwiches ain't
gonna be 20 forever
22 i'm like 15 years wait till you're my
age buddy you're going to look at carbs
totally doing it while it lasts
so me go for it if you know anything
about me i'm eating low carb raps you
know you know you understand sean has
got you on that team
you know vibe pat's eating egg whites by
the way how are the egg whites this
morning this is a big deal
ten times better no thank you just the
whites
so boom we're all in the kitchen
yesterday it's probably around 6 6 30
days winding down
hr situation complaint kai who ate my
muffin
somebody literally ate your mom making
accusations somebody wanted and i had it
in the freezer this was
on friday and i was the whole day i was
kind of looking forward to eating
when they warmed it up they took the
time and they ate it yes yeah that's not
an hr system
and it was a problem
i don't know listen listen i know what
it's like to be falsely accused now
because he
pinned it on me goes i know it was you
you left early on friday
you stole the muffin and left early
friday boom you're guilty right and i'm
like
dude i haven't had a carb since like
2002. now i'm stealing money did you
guys figure out who took them yeah
here's the deal
so i went so mickey is
we were doing wages we were doing wagers
we think it's mario
is it eduardo it could have been eduardo
just got in from venezuela boom
so i said listen i'm going to make a
formal hr complaint we're going to
sit the situation now we're going to
figure it out this muffin fresca
the muffin yeah so i go to hr hr is none
other than
yeah mickey i said mickey we have a case
of the missing muffin she goes oh
i ate the muffin she didn't say that
yeah yes straight up
she smiled no did denial she goes out of
this panic attack sugar attack friday
had to have the muffin i go mickey
i got a hr you hr we got a missing
muffin
wow i mean this is where you see kai's
ugly side steals his carbs
i mean you were ruthless must've been a
good muffin yeah i mean
delicious listen shout out to mickey
yeah shout out to mickey shout out so
what
is she getting you back on the muffler
you guys all right i owe you one i'm
like
just so i don't undersell this kai how
heated were you on this muffin
no i was just marking my territory okay
that makes sense
it's a brand new office we're not even a
week in and people are stealing food
yeah put your name on it there you go
that's typically way to do it put your
name on the bag and that's what we did
in the other office you guys will figure
it out it's gonna be all right
kai will write it in frosting you know
even more calories
there it is okay so let's get right into
it we got spax
what is a spec spac why is everybody
talking about spax why is shamat in a
spec why is serena williams in a spec
why is steph curry in a spot why is
shaquille o'neal in a spec
a-rod billy bean tillman frittata billy
foley
uh even kaepernick just got into a spec
yeah pretty interesting a lot of people
aren't specs we'll talk about that is it
going mainstream
um then you got uh parlor announces it's
back online with no hosting service
you know was that time yeah exactly
jaguar
land rover's car range to be fully
electric by
2030. bumble's founder
whitney fole heard becomes the youngest
self-made women billionaire after
ipo morgan and morgan stanley are eyeing
bitcoin
a big number by the way uh which by the
way bitcoin just crossed 50k
uh anybody else want to help apple uh
build an electric car
another big auto brand said no thanks
reddit raised a quarter of a billion we
may get into that today
is there a mood difference between biden
and trump i'd be curious you know what
zenor has to say about this
senate acquits trump and impeach trial
can you imagine like
so grandpa tell me the craziest thing
you ever did in life well i gotta quit
it twice as a president
yeah but he's gonna spin it it was
unbelievable no one has ever been
acquitted twice
i've been so far but more times
acquitted than any other president oh my
gosh
clinton could only do it once i'm
doubling him yeah california says
newsome recall driven by small business
owners by the way they got the votes
we'll cover that cuomo covered cover
cover-up hits nearly 1900 nursing homes
home death
which uh he is now blaming it on
politics yesterday i don't know if you
guys saw that or not
2.8 million texans are without power as
the state battles an unprecedented
winter storm
nevada casino east corona virus capacity
restrictions monday which is a very very
good sign for concerts events
all of that just going to vegas new
yorkers are fleeing to palm beach out of
all the place why would you go to south
florida i don't understand why you would
want to move towards
your society stay in new york stay in
new york stay in new york
nyc till i die new york city businesses
are following
israel plans to reopen gyms malls and
hotels but a big but only for people who
have been vaccinated
and uh let me see what else i got we're
gonna bother we got a list i asked kai
to pull up the list
of uh uh people who've been banned from
twitter and it'd be interesting to go
through some of these names that we got
on who has been banned from twitter
because
it feel is this a new thing like banning
people has twitter been banning people
for years
is it no let's just kind of see where
that's at how long has it been going on
yeah
and then the end of uh end of era of old
people
meaning old p why are old people winning
at the highest level right now yeah so
so so we'll get into that matter of fact
why don't we just start off with that
era of old people
so tom why don't you take the lead with
this you know a lot of things are going
on right now what do you think
is this a should we be paying attention
to why
all people are kicking major tail right
now 100 how can you not
okay this is the error of the young
person sorry
jen whatever you are all you um
here's the here's the facts okay so yeah
bruce arians win the super bowl
68 years old oldest super bowl coach to
ever win the super bowl
i mean belichick acts grumpier and older
but he's actually younger
you have president trump who was 72 you
have joe biden replacing him he's 78
or staying in sports you have serena
she's 39.
she had a baby like what three four
years ago and she's still dominating
she's in the semi-finals at the
australian open
you've got lebron no one can touch him
right now lakers are probably going to
win another
title he's 36. he's going tom brady 39.
no no 43. yeah 43. tom brady 43. you got
dr fausti who's 80. you got nancy pelosi
who's 80.
i don't think that you can have that
much of a coincidence where that many
older people are dominating now is nancy
pelosi and
fausti doing anything great no that's
called longevity they've just been able
to hold on to the job
but everybody's going to emulate what
these athletes are doing without a doubt
and aryans were supposed to be done
i mean he's he goes against the norm for
every coach in the nfl they're grinding
all day 18-hour days watching film
he's kicking it back in tampa having a
cocktail at the end of the night and it
worked
i think if you're smart enough to
surround yourself with great people
lebron was 35 when the lakers sucked
okay he was still old and they sucked
the next year he got anthony davis he
got other great players
tom brady looked like he was on a
decline until he leaves bill belichick
starts getting his friends in there like
gronk and everybody they win another
super bowl
serena is just an animal i mean she just
refuses to become mediocre
and so there is i think it's a great
sign because i don't think you only want
young people running everything there's
something about experience there's
something about
wisdom that you can lead and stuff now
i'm not saying everybody has to do it
but i think it's more of a
more than just a coincidence because you
have nutrition that's improved
fitness you're able to live longer
there's so many things that are working
in the factors
that benefit older people if you still
got the drive
and the hunger and you want it if you
don't you're irrelevant and it doesn't
matter
but you can you can go longer at an
elite level if
you make plans to do it what a great
point what a great opening point tom
adams
i mean you know we're in our 40s late
40s
okay careful listening they don't know
doing okay
great point by tom yeah okay can't
dispute that um
something that i talk about in my
business life settlements like you know
longevity
something that i also talk about in
personal finance is that people are
living longer like the retirement is
being reinvented i just did that
interview with kiyosaki
where traditionally our grandparents or
great grandparent whatever it is at this
point however
old you are you life expectancy in the
united states 100 years ago was like
67 years old right now life expectancy
is easily into your 80s if you take care
of yourself
obviously you know these days with covet
pre-existing conditions not taking care
of yourself but you could live to 90 100
no problem in the united states of
america these days if you just take care
of yourself
right so overall as a country we are
reinventing
longevity what do all these guys that
you said are living longer have in
common you said you said experience
wisdom nutrition
drive what else do they have they have
talent around them i think which helps
talent
they can afford like a serena williams
and a tom brady they can afford the
millions of dollars it takes to be at
that
level with trainers okay so there you go
so go there you you said
it they have they can afford what they
they can afford the things that can
compete uh
allow them to compete at the highest
level which is the great nutritionist
the personal code that's
very big right there you know you know
what's the country in the world with the
longest life expectancy in the world i'm
going to guess it's norway or something
in europe
monaco yeah 89 and a half good living
out there 89
because it's the wealthiest country
because it's the wealthiest country in
the world
you can afford better healthcare you can
afford to go see the doctor so there is
maybe there is some you know correlation
between wealth and health 100
so when people say wealthy because you
know back in the days and
in the 20s and the 30s when they would
make the cartoons of wealthy people who
was it it was the guy
the big bang exactly the railroad guy
that's not the case today anymore it's
change it's slender it's in shape that's
what a personal
trainer is doing yoga you know if you've
worked hard
that hard to accumulate that type of
wealth don't you want to stay alive to
enjoy it
right and you have that advantage and
you can right now yeah i think the
biggest
reason people die younger is because
they're so hard on their bodies i mean
you're
you're reckless with your diet and
things like there's so many ways to kill
yourself
if you want to just the way the food
companies put preservatives in
everything and it's out there if you
want to do it but you can also take the
other route
and really defeat those odds and live
almost as long as you want if you take
care of yourself
and try to be disciplined as much as
what did they call it back in the day uh
the gout was called the the the kings
disease or what was it called
oh because only they would all eat red
meat and and wine and you would just
like
deteriorate your entire body in your
existence now we went over tom brady's
regimen the day after the super bowl i
mean the guy is up at 5 30
doesn't eat certain foods works out you
know protein shakes
he started training again the other day
training i mean he was drunk [ __ ] after
the super bowl but that's a whole
different topic that felt great but
listen if if you're if you're listening
to this and you're
and you got somebody in the family
that's kind of like well i feel like i'm
old i feel like i'm this like they need
to hear
this message what would you say that
needs to be shared with them and say
dad can you go listen to this can you
mom can you go listen to this
because a part of this is as well
attitude
i think it's an awesome attitude thing
you know did i tell the story on the
podcast about uh
john d rockefeller have we talked about
the rockefeller i got a little bit of a
glitch going on here
me too uh uh it's one of ours i don't
know who it is
can you guys hear it okay it's gone do
we talk about the john d rockefeller
story last time
so johnny rockefeller when he's a little
kid he said there's two things i want to
do in life i want to make a hundred
thousand dollars
which in today's money he made 350
billion dollars a hundred thousand
dollars he said he wants to make
no no no no no no no he said he wants to
make his eventual wealth when he died
in today's money with inflation it's 350
billion dollars of today's wealth that's
bezos and musk combined
that's rockefeller when he was a kid he
said i want to make a hundred thousand
dollars and i want to live live
up to 100 years old wow he was born in
1835 18
1835 you know how old he was when he
died
late 90s maybe 97 and 11 months
at a time where the life expectancy was
39 and a half for a man
39 and a half life expectancy was 39 and
a half in 1835
in 1835 the average life expectancy was
39 and a half
he lived 97 years and 11 months he was
two years and a month away from reaching
that hundred
year old wow that's like time right
crazy stuff
yep but here's the question here's a
question today
with what we have with today's
rockefeller waking up and you know six
years old 10 years old saying
when i grow up i want to have you know a
trillion dollars or a billion dollars or
whatever it is and i want to live up to
what is that number today
i think the kid's going to say a hundred
i i think i don't think anyone is going
to say i want to live to be 110 because
i don't know how good your life is going
to be but i think in the past maybe you
say 85
90 i'm going to say what do you think
today today kids being
guys i'm actually curious in okay i may
come to you as well what do you think
kids being born to like let's just say a
dash
stud right i mean he's got a little
injury right now with dash is she's
going to be 12 next week happy early
birthday today
take a eight-year-old kid take a
ten-year-old kid driven kid
i'm gonna go out there and do this how
old do you think the oldest person is
gonna be that's eight
ten twelve years old today i can speak
for dash he'll say 13. because there's a
20 stair rail he's going to try to go
down there and he'll probably knock
himself out well there was an article
uh it was a cover story i think time
magazine a handful of years ago
that babies being born today are going
to live to age 130 150. something crazy
like that
i don't know like yeah you think it's
capable it's possible that some people
may look 150
i do and here's why because look how
medicine is advancing look at the
technology
when we start really figuring out some
of these diseases cancer wipes out so
many people what if they got their
handle on cancer
so if you were born with you know
something in your body that
pre-determines that you're going to get
cancer and you can eliminate that
boom 20 of people are going to live
longer automatically maybe a whole lot
longer people maybe get away from
the heart disease issues that kill so
many people maybe driving cars
they're autonomous and it's safer on the
road you know there's less drunk drivers
i don't know but i do believe 130 to 150
is a possibility
because nothing surprises me anymore
what do you guys think if you're
watching this
if you think people kids who are 8 10 12
years old today
can live up to 150 years old smash the
thumbs up button
if you think pat you guys are out of
your mind no way in the world they're
going to live maybe 90 100 110.
smash the thumbs down button i'm
actually curious what the audience
thinks you hear stories
even now i think some uh uh a
nun in france a hundred and ten years
old just beat kovitz 116. she's never
had 16. 116 beat coveted insane yeah
insane 106.
thinking about her she's never put
anything bad into her body probably
right
living on a convent you know she's
praying she's doing her thing you know i
think there's one more factor that's
involved and you kind of mentioned it
it's a motivation
what motivates you to want to live that
long and the perfect example is jeff
bezos and the transformation that he's
gone under
physically since he's in the last 10 or
years and since he's had the new
girlfriend have you seen he's buffed
he's dressing differently fashion is
important
he seems to have a totally different
motivation and if you have that reason
to
live really long you're going to do all
the little things in your life that will
allow you to but you got to find that
one motivation that'll get you there
i'll say one thing and then i want to
get your opinion um
you talked about motivation which we
talked about we talked about
attitude uh you know you talked about
reinventing yourself rediscovering
re-energizing re-everything
reinvigorating yeah
you know to the 40-year-olds are out
there i have friends who are 40.
and they're like oh i've got two kids
i've already done what i had to do
i'm getting old i'm like bro you're
freaking 40. yeah i'm 40. i'm a man you
remember
you ever seen that before what are you
talking about i've already i'm too old
40 bro there's a list of people who
completely started companies after the
age of 40. 40 is nothing these days
moving forward let's say you're in your
60s i'll give you two tales
my stepdad is in his late 60s complete
mess
has given up on life he's his health is
horrible listening to this
he's not listening he's a complete mess
i have my uncle who's
happy he's giving you a hard time you're
going to be alright he's trying to
motivate you i promise you
he's given up no motivation not
reinventing himself
i'm 68 years old yeah i have my uncle
who's 70
wealthy guy works out every day takes
care of himself
constantly coming up with business
that's ross's dad
complete stud same age so this has
talked about motivation that talks about
attitude
yeah so i'll know when i'm getting old
so
udonis haslam he's the the long you know
i played against him in high school he's
sitting on the end of the yeah for real
yeah in miami he's 40 years old now
i played against mel he's still in the
league sitting at the end of the bench
on the miami heat so and i've known the
guy like off and on for 20 freaking
years now
so when i see him at games i used to go
to the games it's always like a head nod
like a respect like keep doing your
thing
he's still there doing his thing 40
years ago cheap coach and you've got
cheap coach millions what you call it
it's a cheap coach veteran
veterans members totally probably makes
it one million bucks how great it is to
have players like that sometimes
respect to someone like howard was a guy
keep everybody in line in the lobby
you got guys younger than kai coming to
the league let me put my hand around you
so
40 years old still doing his thing tom
brady 43. uh lebron 37.
i don't know if haslam is in the same
league as brady but i get what you're
doing no but i'm just saying he's your
friend haslam he likes you
he he's an og in miami we're here in
south florida so here's my question to
you guys
we talked about age talk about age do
you
want to live to age 100 is that a number
you want to live to
because for me 100 i want to go that
long i would you know i
wouldn't i wouldn't mind living 200.
yeah
it's it's not something i said i'm going
to live to 100 yet i haven't i haven't
said that it's not like
you know i'm going to go out there and
live 200. but i think i would have been
living 200.
um the the gentleman uh kirk krikorian
yeah 99 98 a hero of yours yeah
big time he lived to almost a hundred
that's what he was 98.99
okay he's he's a small body frame
yeah he's a little dude 5'4 it's a
different story when you're five
six four six four saying that the
littler you are the
that's a better thing of course it is
really you have you have you have
less things that could go back knees
you know your arms are a mess yeah so no
no we are that's not
listen lebron is six eight so it's not
an excuse i'm making but you know it's
different when it's taller gotcha versus
show but yeah 97 98 years old
100 you want to get to a hundred 100
would be how about you how would you
compound yeah i'm not going to attach a
number to it i just want to keep
being healthy and i'll i'll take it to
120 or bow out at 88 if i'm not
you're putting pressure under time with
his hands i'm just excited you're
already going back baby the the og the
veteran okay
so that was that was a very very good
opening pick me up for yes i would
highly share that part of it with your
family to listen to that okay so
um elon musk asks putin
if he wants to have a conversation with
him on clubhouse
can you imagine hey uh uh
vladimir putin uh
you know will you please come and join
me on clubhouse you speak russian
uh no i don't speak russian i've had
russian friends but i don't speak
russian okay so
teslacio elon musk on saturday as
russian president vladimir putin if he
was interested in having a conversation
on clubhouse the up and coming social
media platform that connects people via
audio chat
audio chat musk tweeted directly to the
official twitter account
of the president of russia asking would
you like me join me in a clubhouse
he followed that with a tweet entirely
in russian
that transit it would be a great honor
to speak with you kremlin called musk's
idea for putin to join clubhouse app
interesting seeking details kremlin
spokesperson dmitry peskov told
reporters on a conference call in
general this is
this is of course a very interesting
proposal but we need to understand what
is
what it's meant what it's being proposed
first we need to check then we will
react we want to figure it out first
president putin does not want per
does not personally use social networks
directly he doesn't have them peskov
said so what what
what's this about you said something
about musk every day there seems to be a
what with muslims there's a big story
yeah he's moving the market he's doing
something he clearly knows it he knows
the power he has
he he's the most influential person on
the planet right now
i mean outside of politics probably you
have to go i don't think i don't think
so i think
you're still outside of politics the
only reason i say that is because some
mad men may have a
finger on a nuclear bomb so that's a lot
of influence if you can just go nuts and
wipe out half the world
outside of some extreme behavior like
that he's the most influential person in
the world
every not not almost every every
day any tweet he sends out is news
it's big news and people are so blindly
following him they will do whatever he
says
i guarantee you there are 10 million
people trying to buy stock in russia
because he sent out that tweet yesterday
even though that's not a company
okay i guarantee you they're calling
their brokers they're going on robin
hood if it's still
real estate property putin's head's
spinning right now because usually i am
the one with the ulterior motive
yeah is that german or russian i don't
even know that's german i'm terrible at
exiting tom now don't go the accent
okay dude do what you do okay so you
know what musk
knows it the question i was wondering to
myself because i'm always writing these
stories on vt post
because anything elon musk if he says
something about bitcoin hey he bought
one point or he invested 1.5 billion
into bitcoin
he said he liked etsy one time the stock
went nuts the next day
even when he promotes a different stock
like a solar wind company
maybe the the nasdaq ticker sign isn't
real common so if you twist one letter
around
that company will go up 15 percent in
one day
he's got he's such a big thinker i i
think there has to be 15 documentaries
done on him i don't know how he does it
you know he's coming to miami and
digging a tunnel for 30 million
they thought it was going to cost a
billion he's going to alleviate traffic
now for 30 million with his boring
company he's doing it in vegas
spacex just launched new rockets today i
mean i don't know how he does it but
he's got
he's not going to reach out to him
without a reason he wants to build a
plant in russia
right he wants to open up russia to
tesla it's a market for him that he's
not into yet and he probably wants to
find a cheap place
to build more cars over there but it
clearly caught putin
off guard on his heels a little bit and
you're not used to seeing him
react like that but he knows it's an
opportunity because if musk calls
something good
is on the other line probably wait wait
wait before check out this this is
this was before and after elon's tweet
and that's not even what he tweeted uh
use signal which
is like an encrypted app um when
whenever
whatsapp announced that they would start
storing the data
and then people went rushed to buy
a public traded company which is called
signal but completely different company
and you just see it jump from what
you're at 60 cents
to seven bucks and by the way it stayed
up after that if you actually give them
credit
it went from being like a 20 cent
company to three dollars that maintained
it
so what do you got to say i mean tom hit
it right on the head i mean he
moves the market just with a tweet with
any single comment three points to make
here on this entire story
number one have we ever seen a business
rock star like
elon musk i mean steve jobs was never a
rock star bill gates not a rock star
warren buffett no not really buddy even
someone like richard branson like that
guy
pales in comparison to elon musk i can't
think jobs is the closest
yeah but he was never i mean jobs you
know rest and rest in power
but he i'm just saying he was the
closest i'm not saying he's right
right but he's nowhere on elon's level
in terms of like the influence and what
he's doing now there was no twitter
there was no
none of that but he was a rock star he
was but he had a call he was a private
person he was a private yeah he wasn't
out there but point is
elon musk is business rock star
social media doing it all moving markets
that's the number one closest thing to
him when you said
like a businessman like that is tony
stark there is nothing
he's the only and it's a movie yeah so
it's iron man that's the closest thing
so that's what we needed to go to the
irony is that tony stark was based off
of
none other than elon musk was he really
and that's
elon musk 10 years ago robert downing jr
went visited elon musk when he was
developing how the character was going
to be
on marvel so there did you know that no
that part i didn't know so you just
intuition it's like your your batman
senses just yeah he's right behind me
right behind you gives me
he's giving you a look so that's number
one so point number two number two
that's great yeah point number two
vladimir putin not have social media
nothing that's russia i don't know
nothing i don't have i don't even know
he's probably interviewing russian wives
right now that's why he knows this is
how he's talking to the brokerage
that's pretty intense no social media
whatsoever no you know
rotus uh you know president of the
russia whatever the hell it is
nothing okay i mean and then the third
point here
is clubhouse clubhouse wasn't even a
thing six months ago i never heard of it
we just heard about it recently well no
they just raised a hundred million
dollars they're valued at a billion
dollars now and they they've had things
going on
but there's a lot of people that are on
there
i've never heard of clubhouse until i
started being with valuetainment less
than six months
sure is when i heard about it and you
said oh you invited me you said here it
joined
this it was like three months ago yeah
but that is the platform that
elon musk invites vladimir putin to do
the interview
pretty intense so those are the three
things elon musk rockstar
vladimir no social media and the rise of
clubhouse by the way if you can get in
clubhouse get in clubhouse because right
now it's only worth a billion and
they're gonna go this this is a
idea that could go to what do you mean
if you can get in
uh investment-wise it's this not given
recommendation
i'm just saying if you similar to a
bitcoin similar to any of those things
take a look at clubhouse in a different
way than just
a uh uh platform sure well let me tell
you this even if it's 5 10
20 50 000. i asked you recently pat who
would you love to interview that you
have never interviewed you said
putin you said putin yeah of course why
putin when did i tell you that
a couple weeks ago why not two weeks ago
kgb why not those stories oh we've
reached out to putin already yeah we
talked to their cam
we talked to their camera regularly i
know this better be david we uh
and we'd like to do a live interview it
wouldn't be a yeah it wouldn't be a
clubhouse
why would you select putin out of
everybody in the world i think he
is the most powerful man in the world
today wow i don't think it's biting
most powerful are you kidding me like
over the chinese president
guys over she or over let me let me put
it to you this way strategy
okay so don't take away what's the best
way to put this
okay uh has popovich ever had a
kobe a lebron a jordan a shack
a kareem has he ever had a player like
almost duncan duncan's not a top five
though okay no
okay so would you put duncan top 10 or
top 20. no top 20. i would have i'm with
you
okay i'm with you but he's never
arguably the best power forward ever
this is not a powerful debate this is
about he never had a michael
a kobe a lebron a chef okay a game
changer so who had two of them who had
three of them
filled with three of them twice well let
me ask you this what if you take those
three out i don't know what phil would
be yeah
and what if you gave those three to pop
i don't know what pop would be i don't
know what lenny wilkins would be if he
had a
i don't know what lenny wilkins is a
thousand win guy i don't know what larry
brown would be we don't know this kind
of stuff
wow take away the country of china
russia u.s
take purely leadership don't take
resources of course china and u.s
resources are ahead who's the best
strategist amongst those three
are you kidding me putin will do laps
between those two other guys yeah and
it's his kgb background i mean wouldn't
you like to dive into that would do
lamps okay if there's a fist fight who
wins
putin if there's a sleepy joke wait a
second biden's got a crutch in his hand
arcane
does that sound funny i know it sucks
that guy right in the chest that it's
all you guys are so funny
no putin is uh putin is uh uh
putin in a fight well it's putin because
who poses shirtless it's putin guys
pose a shirtless on top of a horse and
he's just like hey you guys want to do
something you know
is any of that just for show for optics
i highly doubt that now listen man you
can't be a
so listen as every country has dirt in
it
i mean dirty politics yeah which country
things got dirtier politics
russia okay can you imagine dirtiest
surviving
and leading a dirty politics
country type of thing that's got that
that kind of you have to be able to know
how to play the game
he's been the president for 20 years now
how do you do that
how do you do that and maintain power
for that long with he poisons his
enemies
how many people poisoned want to throw
you under the bus and he still maintain
it
you got to give the guy well he handled
what he's done all the ogilrs in that
country
all the people that by the way i'm not
endorsing the system don't take it as an
endorsement this is not enough i'm just
telling you
he is the most powerful person right now
wow yeah so that's your selection of who
you would love
so now i got a weird question for you
guys i got a weird question for you guys
here's my weird question for you
so we just talked about the era of old
people then we talk about elon musk
and we talk about elon musk inviting
putin then you said every day elon musk
is relevant
okay is elon musk one
dumb tweet away from being suspended and
permanently suspended from twitter
that's the question
okay i'm gonna well you want an answer
right i'm curious i'm gonna say no
i would say he's got more leash than one
dumb because he's good for twitter
all right every time you hear about elon
being in the news it's because of
twitter
trump was bad for twitter
twitter business-wise okay i'm just
answering the question you asked
i do not believe he's one dumb tweet
away
i think he's earned enough equity where
he could have two or three
he's not dumb enough to do it or he has
the same card that he'll be forgiven
both
he's clearly not that stupid where he's
going to do something like that can i
make two other points about musk real
quickly number one
um it was 11 degrees in moscow yesterday
and eight degrees in austin texas so
maybe he wants to move there who knows
that's why he called putin
number two though seriously you know you
think about social media influencers or
people that have
influence that have a following that
people respond to what do brands do for
them they bring them money so they post
right it pushes the brand makes them
money elon musk
is immune to that like an insider
trading situation hey can you do one
tweet on my company it'll blow up
he's already the richest person in the
world there's no financial benefit for
him
individually to ever do something
because you'd always ask yourself when
you have
that much power and that much sway and
so many disciples that will do whatever
you say to do with
a five-word tweet are you susceptible to
being bribed
insider trading taking something that's
unethical or doing something and using
that power in a negative way he could
never do it for financial reasons
because he doesn't have to he's already
the richest guy in the world
would twitter ever ban elon musk that's
the question
yes right because it's a two it's a two
prong question
one is would he ever post something
dumb enough that would jeopardize him
staying on
twitter and number two would twitter
ever have the audacity to say we were
permanently banned
i think if he does do that just going on
track record
i'm gonna have to say yes why would i
say yes number one
he's done some stupid stuff that has
moved uh
look for all the kudos that were given
elon musk he's also done stuff that has
hurt the brand and the stock
like i could see either the you know
board of directors or even self-imposed
being like dude put down the twitter for
a second i could see that
you he went on joe rogan podcast smoked
a blunt that did not help the company
i could see that thing and then if
twitter has any track record
for silencing voices especially more
conservative voices i
i politically i think that elon musk is
center right
right i don't know how far right he is
he's certainly not a leftist or anything
like that i think he's more center-right
he's obviously a capitalist
for sure can i see him saying something
so outlandish or so from his perspective
what he thinks is right but you know the
leftist whoever's controlling twitter
thinks is wrong i think it could happen
uh do i want it to happen
am i rooting for elon musk am i rooting
for his companies and you know space
travel hell yeah
but based on track record things that
he's said and what twitter has done or
social media
has done to write leaning voices it's
possible yes
do you what do you think so so here's
how i process that here's how i process
this
when you get a person like that that is
that eccentric mind nonstop working
you know take mark take a howard hughes
okay
and take uh tony stark the character
howard hughes real character
tony stark you know fictional character
iron man right the
robert downey jr okay there was a part
about
the girl that plays in iron man that
dude just shut your mouth and stay down
here don't say
anything to the media i don't know if
you remember that relationship
yes yes well she's kind of like dude
just don't say anything you get in front
of mike's like oh screw it here's what
i'm doing you know what we're going
dude just be quiet right does musk like
is musk the kind of guy that behind
closed doors
you tell him not to say something he
won't say it i don't think so
i think if musk wants to say something
he'll say now let me flip it
so so i do think there's an element of
that let me go to a different direction
howard hughes is there an element of a
musk that he could get
bored out of his mind that he may want
to do something crazy i don't know
you know he he's gonna in his brain like
he sees things that the world doesn't
see yeah he sees the world from a
different place
but i have a neural link but i'll give
you the last one here i'll give you the
last one here why
i don't think it would happen here's
what i don't think it would happen
i don't think it would happen because he
came from the paypal mafia community
and that entire community is all
connected okay and they all work
together yeah
and somebody would make the call and say
elon just so you know you're gonna get a
slap and you're
gonna have to spend you for like a day
or something but you're gonna get back
on just don't do that again bro like
you ain't helping yourself okay you know
and then he's gonna go back to what he's
doing because he
came from that yeah so where are we
going with this we're going with
uh what do you call it uh people that
have been suspended on
twitter kai you may want to move the
screen because the screen just blacked
out guy
okay it says hdmi so okay
so trump he got banned from twitter
right do you give credit
to some of these guys elon musk for
knowing how to build
allies i don't know because a part of
this is also having allies
did trump have any allies in silicon
valley
i don't know if he had any allies peter
too no one public though
peter thiel is not he's influential
but he's not as influential as some of
these other guys that are the you know
dorsey some of these zuck some of these
guys right okay he got close to tim cook
if you remember tim cook came in
but does tim cook have more power than
zuck does tim cook have more power than
uh what do you call it dorsey when it
comes down to i think so when it comes
down to
influence i don't think so because trump
doesn't need an app
like apple's power is in the app
like we will not let your app be there
but trump's power is he needs to
communicate through what
twitter or a facebook which is a
platform apple's not a platform
apple's a company that access those
platforms through your phone
yeah but that means apple would have to
ban facebook and they're never going to
do that
apple would have to bla pants so they
are in a little tip right now they are
but it's different to
communicate there's no way apple would
if they ban facebook it would be
insane if they did that yeah trump's a
bit of an outlier though because
we're talking about aga i mean what they
said he did
starting an insurrection and a riot in
that and there's there's a difference
between that
and whatever musk or anybody else is
even capable of tweeting right i mean
something that ended up with the capital
being stormed is a little bit different
you know
he's got so much influence musk i think
twitter's got to be afraid of him number
one and number two couldn't he just snap
them up or put them out if he wanted to
or or really seriously hurt them
if they did something to him these are
200 billion yeah twitter's a 40 billion
dollar company i want to come and buy
you and you're out
you know but but dorsey is a guy that
wanted to be a fashion designer right
so dorsey is also not the guy that
wanted to be a billionaire like dorsey
doesn't give a crap about being a
billionaire like
dorsey's not the you know the the
billionaire dorsey
he's growing a homeless man he's not
he's not at all the guy that's like the
typical
i'm gonna go take over the world that's
not that's not the worst you're saying
like an accidental billionaire
you know he's he's actually a i think
deep down inside has an
activist bone to him and he really
disagrees with some of the philosophical
views even if it costs him five billion
dollars or two
i don't think he cares he has principles
values and principles i think he's a
true believer
i don't in what he believes in okay and
what he
i think he's a true believer in what he
believes in let me let me even if it
costs some money let me circle back to
the trump and
your initial question you know allies
allies
the problem with trump is by the way if
you're enjoying the dialogue with the
way it's going on the podcast with the
three of us here today
and this is your first time joining us
on the podcast you have no clue what's
going on but you're liking it smash that
subscribe button
uh once we get to 100 000 subs we're
considering doing this possibly three
times a week
once it gets to a hundred thousand we
got 53 000 more to go but go ahead you
were talking about allies
shout out to martin mirage he says the
paypal mafia
over the soyboy mafia i don't know about
that i don't know about that these days
adam's wearing those shorts they'll
retreat yeah they'll run away a good
point
submit so if somebody posts a picture of
his shorts or let's get that out there
guys
go ahead let's get that the shorts
we almost got kicked out of the building
yeah you want to call me when udonis
was dunking on him that's the shorts he
was wearing yeah
the old school old school 50s nba 60s
nba
george michael all the way to the top
so back to allies back to allies and
this is like
i can't believe i'm referencing
something my mom would tell me in
kindergarten but she would tell me
um with the voice with the voice i'll do
it she would say
um to have a friend you need to be a
friend
to have a friend you need to be a friend
i was like all right like let me i gotta
i gotta be a friend to you if you could
be a friend of me
the problem with trump is he uses you he
chews you up and he spits you out
anyone who's left that um
uh team or whatever you want to call it
the cabinet
in out in out any i mean we can go down
the list i'm just gonna you know
you know go off the off the cuff here
rex tillerson was there
does not like him now anthony scaramucci
your boy was there for like a hot seven
days
out um what's my uh general kelly
in out i mean omarosa omarosa in out
you don't hear those stories about elon
musk you don't hear oh
i worked with elon and he was a piece of
[ __ ] and he's fired me
you don't hear those you hear those
about trump so
you talked about allies i think to your
credit to your point
trump uh musk makes a call to whether
it's a dorsey whether it's a zook
whether it's a
cook whether it's a penny off whatever
it is
and says look man this that is that
let's work it out
there you know intermediaries takes a
friend to be a friend i think he's got
true allies
where trump his legacy is he'll use you
abuse you and then spit you out
i mean listen there's there's proof to
show that that did take place and
there's proof on elan as well
elon's created a lot of enemies in a
different way steve jobs had a lot of
enemies where
i don't know if you've ever read the
book accidental millionaire not
accidental billionaire accidental
millionaire was written in the 80s maybe
early 90s
it's a fascinating book but you know
what the book it's actually written in
95 i believe
not the millionaire next door no
different accidental millionaire
can you pull up accidental millionaires
just apple's old logo the rainbow
logo book accidental millionaire book i
want to know when it was written
nice shout out to kai's spelling great
go to go to amazon go to amazon right
there
no go to amazon yeah click on that there
you go
see if it comes that's not the book
though uh that you see that's the thing
no one can find a book
go back oh there it is that's the one
look how many reviews it's got
eight reviews lee butcher okay what's
going on here this book go down to see
when this book came out go down i mean
who reads this book only
1987 this book came out the entire book
is trashing jobs
no seriously the entire book is trashing
jobs who was it written by
by people that got fired by him or let
go by him so
jobs and trump had a little bit of a
thing and you know jobs was like in the
middle of
if musk is here trump is here jobs was
here because jobs had a little bit of
trump going in him as well
but can you can you tell me when did
twitter come out
when did twitter come out kai exactly
when the twitter comes out 607.
because the question is going to follow
up with when did twitter start
what year 06. okay when did
twitter first permanently ban its first
user oh
good question o6 they got started when
do you think was the first time they
permanently
banned the users i'd love to get our
audience i'm curious let's get the
audience here don't google it don't be
that guy that googles
don't do it now i got the right answer
like who do you think it is yeah
when do you think the first time not the
first person but first time
they permanently banned somebody so
isn't the first time the first person
yeah but not the name i'm not looking
for the name next year because or the
right way
soon so you're saying within a year just
because someone's going to do something
so stupid you got it
what would you say take the other side
of that i think it's like more recent
history
i think it's like 20
okay so you're saying eight years later
uh kai do you already know the answer to
this question so i'm not gonna ask you
paul when do you think was the first
time twitter
after being around 2006 when is the
first time they banned somebody
you know i'm going to go with 2009
okay by the way paul wins because it's
2010. okay
it's december 8th 2010 they banned
operation
payback handle a non-underscore
operation anonymous
hackath hacktivist campaign in support
of online piracy and wikileaks
permanently banned okay so that's why
they banned him the next one is courtney
love
january 2011. yes courtney
baptist yes courtney love american
musician and actress was banned
permanently original account days after
fashion designer don
uh filed a defamation suit against love
over tweets made on march 17
29 2009 it was the first high-profile
defamation trial over celebrity comments
on twitter wow
love now uses a different account
courtney she's on
back on but her first hand and behaving
and behaving but the first one was gone
so
then it's another guy that happens in
2011 a norwegian
far-right terrorist no joke okay and
perpetrator
2011 norway attacks and how do you say
anders
is that the guy that went to the summer
camp yes his account was hacked by the
nominees
he said they would oh god okay so so
there you go
some names that they have obviously
anonymous i don't know if you remember
anonymous used to do those videos before
with the mask do you remember they used
to be big everybody used to follow
yeah you don't see a lot of them now and
then uh hamas was taken out in 2014.
phil mason since the
palestinian uh yeah exactly military
wing of hamas
is brigades
was taken down you got a bunch of
different names that they're going
through right so so
you know pewdiepie was temporarily
suspended for being pretending to be a
member of isil
what i mean you have to be a fool to do
that but the pewdiepie 100 million
subscriber acted like he was a member of
isil yeah obviously you're going to get
taken down for that
and then jack dorsey was taken down
november 2016. after restoring his
account dorsey tweeted the suspension
was due to an internal mistake
the founder and ceo i bet you one of his
own employees played a joke on him
suspended him that's a great story so
anyways then you got a bunch of
different stories on what it is right i
mean you got a bunch of different
stories they can go through on who it is
roger stone got banned permanent october
2017.
[Music]
uh uh so so the the the the names you're
looking at
are relatively reasonable candace owns
got
temporary band august 5th 2018.
uh you got a sabo was permanently banned
street artist
uh chris paronto was temporary banned
okay
september 8 september 10 2018 using the
words
[ __ ] in a hashtag uh he says you're an
idiot
and he uses a line from the movie uh uh
tropic thunder
never go full [ __ ] yeah that's so so
the hashtag it was temporary
everybody know that everybody knows no
james woods who if you don't know james
woods is a big twitter user
anything with infowars by the way look
at this it's like 15
accounts they took down james was
permanent no he's not he came back it
was temporary he came back
i loved him yeah you know and you got a
bunch of different names
by the way james woods was temporary uh
banned a few times it's not just once
that he went through it and then you
lead to trump and then now you got
you know katie hopkins that is
permanently banned that if you guys know
who
katie topkins is candace owns a couple
times and
recently
charlie kirk temporary david ike
permanently
and you got don bongino temporarily
michael flynn permanently
sydney powell jim watkins ron watkins
all permanently
do you think there is a trend of
consistency or
extremes thoughts you know what i i'm
going to just be a rational human being
here for a couple seconds and i think
it's consistent
i think whenever you do something you
got to know what the rules are and if
you want to play with fire you can get
burned okay
so i don't have a big problem with it uh
it's a huge platform they're gonna have
to police it some way
and if there's people doing things that
they shouldn't be doing now you don't
want
just immediately this is company policy
anybody that thinks a certain way
has no chance to proclaim their voice on
our platform
you don't want that obviously but from
what you just read
it seems like they've done something to
probably deserve it
yeah i thought we were it was going to
be a list of conservative names i didn't
think it was a
going to go back this far to courtney
loves of the world i just wanna uh
big-time rapper talib quali i saw him on
the list a few times permanent ban
i thought this was gonna be a list of
right-leaning conservative voices oh
there's silence in the right
they wanna they don't wanna hear the
truth i thought that that's where this
was going
but in actuality they just want
truth and not misinformation i don't
think it's
truth i don't think it's truth because
you have to be careful when you say
truth
is it your truth my truth something's
his opinion they don't want
to be blatant lies or manufacturing then
you would take
30 of your guys out i mean you if you if
it's blatant lies you could take 30
of the guys out i think what they're
looking for is is
insinuating or trying to
create fights or you know getting
excitement
and yeah that that that's what you're
that's what you got to be careful with
you know
and then some of them is definition of
carry you go after somebody too hard you
know hey what are you doing like
you can't do this you just can't do
things like that um
but uh yeah i mean i don't know look
there's there's a community that says
you they're absolutely targeting and
there's a community that says they're
not targeting
if you look at the list of names that
you're looking at here i think there's a
level of consistency
on what's going on here with twitter so
it's not political it's
just guidelines whether you're left
right i don't
know about permanently banning a
president
is the right thing to do i don't know if
permanently banning good prayers you
know what i would have done here's what
i would have done
look you like for example we have guys
that sell insurance in insurance you
advance right meaning i give you 100
advance okay you
get a 200 month policy typically
insurance companies will advance you
six months nine months ten months twelve
months so if i do two hundred dollars a
month twenty four hundred dollars says
the target premium
i give you twenty four hundred dollars
up front you're at fifty percent you
make 1200 bucks okay that's insurance
that's how
allows insurance guys to stick around
because they're making money
up front but if your quality of business
sucks
we take that away so you get a 200 check
from a client then we only pay you as
earns which means what
you cut a 200 check you get 50 of what
that 200
which is what 100 bucks you'll get the
other 200 next month
and it goes as earned i would have done
of your tweets have to go through
screening process
approved goes out for six to 12 months
until we feel confident and then
we'll take it down that's what i would
have done i would have gone
full out the direction that went and
guess what if 100
and some people say well we don't have
that kind of staff it's one person
they do this with it's a president you
make an exception you make
one person's job is to sit there with a
committee of four other people two of
them are conservative two of them are
liberals one of them is independent
that's how i would do it
two liberal two conservative one
independent hash it out this one can't
go up
this word needs to change and then you
have an approval process are you
comfortable changing this word or this
tweet can not go out
that the trump did tweet a lot though
there'd be a lot of a lot of tweets to
look at it but you've got five employees
that handle one account that's the
president that's not a big deal right
five times
month there's a lot of people that wish
that trump had some sort of vetting
process in his four years of
freedom of speech look i think they're
smart i think the smart move for twitter
say it's six months banned
then you can try to come back and if you
misstep you're gone for good because
look at the publicity they'd get in six
months everybody's waiting for that
first tweet
what's he gonna say yeah yeah there's
there's many ways you could have done it
they had their own reasons they did what
they did so okay parlor is back okay
parlo announces is back online with new
hosting service after month of being
offline the social media platform parlor
relaunched
on monday the company announced that the
site was up and running with a tea party
co-founder serving as interim ceo
mark meckler an attorney political
activist the founder of tea party
patriots replaced former ceo and
co-founder john matsey
who was fired by the company's board
earlier this month parlor which has more
than 20 million users was first launched
in august of 2018 is currently back
online for users
and will be available for new users
starting next week according to
publicity available uh whose data the
domain is registered with epic
which also hosts gab another far-right
social media platform last month amazon
web services decided to suspend upstairs
social media platform to fellow moderate
egregious apple and google have three
previously suspended parlor from its app
stores
earlier this month partly tournament
okay so thoughts on this move taking
place
i'm not into the extreme movement on
either side so they don't interest me
i'm not interested in parlor
if that company had a brand like what
they're perceived as as maybe someone
that's objective and looking at so you
mean to tell me for a guy that's as
active on social media as you are like
you use it 24 7. you're not on par
parlor yet like i said i'm going to
approach this as a rational human being
and let me get back to my point about
their profile
touche parlor i look at them
if you were to describe them they're
weak they're they're a
sad story tough luck you know their
ex-ceos going on the rounds complaining
about getting fired
you're going to have x amount of people
that are going to want this where they
can only speak their views and the only
people listening to them
are the exact same people it just should
be called clone.clone.com or something
i'm just not into it i don't think
they're ever going to be
anything that's a huge factor and
especially right now
when the republicans don't have as much
say nationally
i just think they're not that relevant
and the fact that they're trying again
is great because they were big in the
news a little while ago and that's good
i guess that they found a place that
they can actually
live on some platform but i'm i just
don't look at them as this is a little
burst in the news
we won't be talking about them in two
weeks question for you 20 million users
what percentage are mega
i'm going to say far right people are um
85 okay
got would you agree with that yeah i
mean okay more maybe i don't know
who in here is on parlor anybody on par
are you on parlor
i mean i set up an account have you ever
posted anything
have we ever posted anything i didn't
even know we had to set up an account
you just did it to protect the name so
nobody comes and takes something
yeah i've never we've never posted
anything and you're not
what no not at all not on parlor sam
maybe
no okay got it uh so 85 percent
conservative who said that is
you know what can you research to see
what percentage of parlor
or mega it's probably more than that but
go ahead so your thoughts on
just a couple different things here
because this is this is a pretty
you know winding story number one uh for
sure you were active on them
no surprisingly let me shock you let's
start with tom i
i could use tom as sort of like a
barometer for like
how far right is this how
center is this because if we've learned
anything from tom
tom is center right obviously
big trump advocate you were you know 33
you were
thought he'd still be president you know
i'm just quoting you bro
yeah but just quote you bro point is
tom but he also has you know common
sense and sensibility and he's from the
midwest and he's got
you know that minnesota nice vibe going
on so if it's too far right for tom that
signals to me
all right this thing's going a little
right here at the same token
something and we've said many times here
the riches are in the niches this is
like the
fox news or the oan for social media
so if you want to kind of be in a far
right echo chamber and only hear things
you agree with
go hang out on parlor because there's
gonna just you know they're gonna be
stirring the pot of everything that you
already believe they're not gonna tell
you anything
that you don't wanna hear so another
thing that we talked about was
who they're gonna kind of bring in to be
the ceo
to make friends with the
big tech of the world i don't know if
this guy uh
mark meckler who is the founder of the
tea party patriots uh
is going to be the guy to kind of lead
them into the promised land
so something that pat always asks is
who do you want to be who do you want to
be
do you want to be a mega social media
platform like a twitter like a facebook
like an instagram
that has all types of voices and debates
and
a lot of different uh opinions going on
or do you only want to be a far right
echo chamber
who do you want to be if the answer is
we want the mega crowd and we just want
to magga it up all day yeah
then you have your answer if you want to
be bigger then go
go a little broader yeah you know what i
i said that they'll be irrelevant in two
weeks
let me let me rehash that i think
they'll be irrelevant in one week
because
when you go out and you hire as the ceo
the former leader of the tea party
are you kidding me that'd be like the
facebook board
kicking out zuckerberg and bringing in
the founder of myspace i mean it's
yeah what the teak party i mean they
don't even existed that's exactly the
direction i was about to go
okay so where tom just went right now is
exactly
by the way fyi was it fair to say when
tom started he was
further right than thomas today can we
recognize this guy
okay and is it fair to say that when you
first started you were further left
than you are today would you agree with
that yeah a little bit like don't don't
say a little bit
when you first came you were way way
different than i had to put down my
antiqua outfit and then join the podcast
by the way if if you see a trend here
this podcast what it does is it brings
us
more center and a little bit more to be
able to reason
and see arguments okay i mean that's
that's the outcome if you think what's
going on we're becoming a little bit
more reasonable
you hear that folks so so you said
something you said uh
i don't even give him two weeks i give
him a week how do you bring the former
leader of tea party et cetera et cetera
okay so
so when they fired a board were you on
it or was it somebody else when we
talked who
was in here who was just me and you okay
when they fired
uh the ceo of parlor he was like 32
years old
they fired him so at that time i said
okay we're gonna find out
we're gonna find out in the next few
weeks whether the board is
smart or the ceo smart because that was
really outside we're going to find out
so i thought the board was going to go
get a
center ceo to show
the aws services look we're the board
we're just the money guys
we are willing to go this direction but
they came back
and they doubled down in their true
belief system which is what
no we're going to bring the tea party
we're even going to go further right and
here's what we're going to do
guess what you have a choice to do that
but so do they okay
they also have a choice to say no we're
not doing that let me explain why let me
explain let me go a little bit deeper
is parlor or a nonprofit no is it a
charity
no is it a uh uh 501 is it a 501
okay so when facebook got started was
their outcome to
uh drive more socialistic philosophies
no when facebook got started what was
the idea was called the facebook they
want to rate hot chicks and your
colleagues well no the facebook was the
name of
harvard's yearbook that's what's called
the facebook so when you go to harvard
their yearbook is called the facebook so
originally it was called the facebook
and they went through the
what they did and their main focus was
what going through ivy league
students so they went to different ivy
leagues then they opened it up to
universities and after universities
opened up to who
the world it wasn't a political legend
it was just hey here
here's where we are right myspace same
thing twitter same thing you go through
all these
this is started politically so this is
specifically politically so here's my
question
do you think a socialist would even
think about getting on parlor
i don't know do you think not unless
they're looking for a fight
if they're looking for a fight a
different story but do you think
someone's like let me go in there
because there's a lot of audience that's
going to be willing to share my content
no you're not going to have that so you
know i was i was hoping
the board would and by the way they have
some smart people part of parlor
they don't have dummies on parlor these
are smart intelligent
people that have done pretty well for
themselves but to go this route i
thought this was a second chance i don't
know what's going to happen with
parliament
i actually i actually think that they're
i actually disagree with tom on the one
week two thing two week thing i'll tell
you why
they're carving their niche man like i
said before the riches are in the niches
they said
we can't compete with the instagram with
the snapchat with the tick tock
with the twitter like yeah we're here
for for the right leaning people
that is why we exist we have political
commentary
that is our brand that is our vibe run
with it
if we need to go find a different amazon
web services
go with it now me personally i'm not
hanging out on parlor i'm not advocating
parlor but i understand the methodology
that they're going i mean
it shows it here like they're like no uh
you're gonna ban us we're gonna go bring
a conservative tea party guy and we're
gonna go further down i get that
but that's their that's who they want i
get that but you have to realize
okay so maybe let me give you okay so
let's
let's show it this way okay this is the
silicon valley mafia
okay this is your belief system okay
of where you are right you are far away
from each other they don't like you you
don't like them you think they're
bullying you and silencing you you think
you know they're idiot socialists
whatever you want to call them there
needs to be a mediator
okay the mediator is the ceo that
reports earnings reports what's going on
communicates with these guys gives them
a little peace of mind and at the same
time guys i'm gonna execute
and grow the company if you get a ceo
here
fine i get it but you go and get a far
right t
like i don't like i don't understand
from a ceo standpoint buddy the ceo has
to be able to like
i have to be able to work both with the
field
and protect them but i have to work with
the carriers for carriers to know i'm
responsible
and i have to work with my investors and
i have to work with my employees
can you imagine if it's just like no
nobody at the field knows what the hell
they're doing no carriers are dumb and
no home office
i just don't understand the logic behind
that yeah i don't get it i'll make one
more point here
i i look at parlor as an app and a
social media platform that was
created from emotion right we want to
have our own
our own place we can go and i think what
this is showing you that
these guys over here that are social
media mafia they will control
what's what's where you're allowed to
even put that up i mean there are so
many
obstacles for you if you want to do it
for that and think about any successful
silicon valley company i mean they're
there to make money these guys are so
smart they graduated from harvard
stanford i mean these are the brilliant
most brilliant people on the planet in
some
areas these guys aren't out to make
money they're just like you said an echo
chamber
i think they're not even it's not a good
business model i think they'll be out of
business
in less than a year what's different
between and
i don't know from a ceo standpoint i
mean but we can talk about
what's different between what they're
doing and what fox news decided to do
years ago everyone's on the left
cnn nbc abc let's go right baby
and we're going to control that audience
no no no no no but i don't know what
roger ailes
and and and those types what's the
difference between these guys
very different climate look when the
climate
changes this is not you know climate
change when the climate changes in any
industry you're a part of
you have to also anticipate and be
prepared for it things change
products change in the insurance
industry regulation changes
in the security you cannot say i don't
care about the new regulation i disagree
because here's what i'm going to be
doing you know no
it's a different climate today it's fair
to say
the biggest web services is controlled
by who bezos
listen i don't care how much you dislike
the guy you have to go through aws
okay if you say you know
i don't care what they're going to do
we're going to put our apps on you know
a a metro pcs dude no one uses pcs
you need to be on apple android i don't
care what anybody else says you know
we're gonna
no no you have to be wiser about your
moves let me give you
a proposal if i was sitting on the board
yeah if i'm on the parlor's board here's
what i would have said guys
we have to go win the trust of who
we have to win the trust of our users
who eighty-five percent are what
matter all right far right it's fine we
have to go earn the trust
of the regulators who are silicon valley
we have to win aws we have to win apple
we have to win uh
droid here's what we're doing we're
going to go out there and say
after extreme investigation okay
we hire teams to come and investigate
everything we
have deleted 117 000 tweets
and we have suspended you know not
tweets messages and we have suspended
1943 you know users on parlor
who use the following things and we have
them they've been permanently banned
okay you come out and you say we're
responsible look
when when when early stages when i'm
running the insurance company
and we had a certain people that had bad
quality business
i publicly went and told carriers here's
why i terminated
here's who lost contract with us so then
i went to the field
because they have to now go to mega and
they're going to say you guys have been
you you flipped this is all about money
for you you don't care about the message
you're not about freedom
you don't care about trump you don't
care about this when trump was doing
with you
so do you cause you could lose your
backlash you have to go to them and say
guys
listen moving forward we just can't do
this kind of stuff
this behavior i don't care who it is if
it's my own family i have to
make a decision and take a stand we're
building a company and do we want this
company to be in business or to be out
of business
we want to be in business the following
criteria is we cannot do
if it happens we have to terminate you
we're making it very clear
this is how it's going to work out if
you do this if you do this if you do
this
freedom of speech doesn't mean i can go
out there and say anything i want i'm
going to take this person out let's go
no there's there's levels to freedom of
speech now
opinion fine yeah inciting
you crossed the line yeah so i think if
they took that plan
and said hey very simple powerpoint
presentation here's what the board has
done the last four weeks since parlour
was taken out to show responsibility to
the marketplace
want this to this three this five points
we're going to talk about today then let
the market say oh wow and we brought the
co
and we have co-ceos we have this ceo
from this side we have this year from
this side
there is ways for these guys to say
let's give him a second chance
and then you go from there i i i i think
they missed the mark
i'm gonna make a prediction and a point
here the prediction is they will
100 be out of business within a year
they will no longer be
around there is no parlor within 12
months i guarantee i feel so confident
that if they are still in business in
one year
i'm buying everyone in this office a
muffin and two
two muffins for the muffin thief she
gets two because i know she loves the
muffins i'm gonna hook her up
i was sleeping over there
it's not a business and i'm going to
tell you why right now
because trump's extreme followers aren't
as loyal as you think they are
they're loyal when he's in the news when
he's on twitter and he's the rah-rah guy
and you can rally behind him and he's
speaking for you
now he's at mar-a-lago now he's silent
now you don't hear from him
it's not his he's not like some radical
lenin or stalin or somebody that gets a
following this cult-like following
he was there because he was loud he was
saying what people wanted to hear he
knew exactly how to push the buttons of
all these people
if he's not relevant politically there's
no maga
there just isn't they don't care that
much they want their country to be great
but they're not supporting that one
figure
which is what he was parlor has no
chance none
wow i don't know i'd love to see thomas
prediction let's circle back in a year
and i hope uh i hope i get a muffin but
by the by the way
i want to read a comment here so this
person said vitamin is a business
venture and patrick is just
adjusting direction according to the new
political reality right and a couple
other people are saying
uh uh that uh you know tom is caving and
this person all this other stuff that
they see in here right that we're
looking at okay
fine no problem no problem
here's here's what people have to
realize what's going on
today we've been publicly
supportive of both trump we've been
publicly supportive of biden
in areas we've been publicly supportive
and
not supportive of trump or biden we have
voted
we voted for left we voted for right i
have voted for both sides politically
i think when you forget like i run a
company with people on the left people
on the right people in the middle people
christian muslim it doesn't matter we
have people from all walks of life in
the company
when you no longer want to hear what the
other side has to say
you have a big problem okay you have a
big problem by the way
i as as much as we talk about these
twitter suspensions that we're talking
about
if it becomes being handed out left and
right freely that's you're playing with
fire right then when you say
like the james o'keefe thing where uh
they took the guy down
but then you saw what he said if you do
this you get your account back and what
did he say
i'm back is it fair to say that here's
project veritas he shows
videos of jack dorsey he throws
jack dorsey under the bus and dorsey
still lets him stay on
i don't know about that i don't know if
you guys don't know what i'm saying or
not so he puts videos of dorsey and puts
videos of executives of twitter
talking about their political agenda and
twitter still keeps them on
why did that happen right that just
happened what are you doing keeping them
on
right so you understand where i'm going
with this absolutely they're not going
to just boot you for what i'm trying to
say is if you keep there
there is a very annoying aspect of what
project
he is very annoying to people on the
left in silicon valley
very annoying because he's calling all
them out he pokes the bear and you let
that guy stay on
yeah yeah so so there has to be how do
you think they let him stay on well
because he hasn't maybe broken the
guidelines yet
and they've given him opportunities to
come back to delete this tweet or do
this and do that and the great
they're i respect that so what i'm
saying to you is i also respect that so
the challenge happens when the far right
folks
don't have the ability to reason and the
challenge happens when far left folks
don't have the ability to reason if you
can't
do that just go to a place where
everybody agrees with you because this
ain't the place
ain't the place that you can agree with
everything we talk about this is not the
podcast for you
go to a completely different place than
here no back to your point of what we're
doing here how tom was a little further
right i was for the left we're bringing
it together you have things that
you know you you're more left on more
right on capitalism
uh social issues you know something that
i think
as a country we need to do better than
is blanket statements if you voted for
trump then you're a racist
yep i'll never speak to you again if you
voted for biden then you're clearly a
communist
you're a socialist i know what you are
you're antifa
if you voted for trump clearly uh you
hate uh
anyone that's different like dude relax
trump's a nazi
dude what are you talking about it's so
freaking extreme to the ability to
reason
the ability to have a conversation that
say tom i disagree with this this
this but i hear you on this this and
this can we agree that
well pat you said like everything that
you said is exactly the reason why we do
this podcast
we want to have different voices coming
together and finding
some commonality here and that's a
problem in this country is the
the the complete just well you this are
you this
it's it's it's messed up and i think
that that needs to be
yeah look i'm here because of the idea
of america which is what freedom of
speech
pro second amendment pro just look at my
safe
you you can go down the list of stuff
that america offers you right free
enterprise all
in freedom of assembly all day long for
you go down freedom of religion what do
you want to be
go be at it you want to be christian
jehovah's seventh day go go for it
all of those things is why many
immigrants like myself are in america
happily
in america i'm gonna do my part to fight
to make sure those things
stay in place having said that you are
absolutely naive if you don't realize
how much influence social media silicon
valley have
and by the way to everybody on the right
that complains about it
do something about it parlor's not the
way to go by the way
partner you ain't look there's a saying
that in business you say bring him in
first
baptize him later okay too many people
want to baptize
before they bring him into the church i
don't know if that saying makes sense
let me explain to what i mean by this so
for example
um i go to a bike shop the other day
you know i want to buy something i'm
gonna spend a few hundred dollars i mean
less than thousand dollars
i said put your mask on i said i forgot
my mask at the house i said you guys got
one of these blue masks no we don't have
the mask go get it yourself
wow so i'm like this guy so i'm like
okay so i go back
i get the mask i come back and i'm
thinking to myself the mask i went on
amazon you can buy 149
449 you can buy 2 000 masks
ends up becoming seven cents a pop yeah
for a mask okay
your seven cents just cost you five
hundred dollars
that 500 profit margin to you is
typically forty percent on the forty
percent you can end up keeping
you know twenty percent say 100 you
would have netted because you got to pay
the employee sales
rent all this stuff you just seven cents
a hundred you tell me which bitcoin
which stock
that you spend seven cents gives you
a hundred dollars not one investment is
going to give you that right okay
so let's just say you are anti-mask
let's just say you say this is stupid
nobody should be wearing a mask
you know we're such followers and sheeps
okay say you believe that
fine is it worth you not having a box of
masks there
to allow a liberal who wears four masks
to come in that spends
a thousand do you care politically where
a person is if they're gonna do business
with you
no that's called capitalism if you only
want to do business
with republicans that's your business
model fine if you only want to do
business with democrats fine
when aoc put her sweater up said what
tax the rich for 68 bucks kevin o'leary
about it
and kevin o'leary said look even an a
even a socialist eventually becomes a
capitalist
he did a video and says hey aoc why
don't you contact me i'd love for us to
start a business together i'd invested
these sweaters here let's do something
together as a capitalist
he's taking a shot at her but even an
aoc understands
she's willing to sell that sweater to a
republican she's willing to sell that
sweater to anybody right
okay so invite him first baptize him
later right
invite him to the church baptize them
later
sometimes if your platform is only
one side you're not going to baptize and
convert people
the name of the game is converting the
name of the game
isn't talking to people who already
agree with you
the name of the game is to convert
people any platform or leader that
converts that's a leader
any leader or platform that's just
talking to the same audience that's
agreeing with you you ain't making any
kind of a change by the way
everybody agrees with you there's no
influence being made and honestly to be
honest and take this even to a different
level
you're actually copping out you're
actually
weaker i don't this makes sense so okay
so so for the christian community
where did he go to want to baptize
people you read the bible where did he
go where did jesus go did he go to
the slums did he go to where everybody
agreed with them
you go to the best sales person where do
you go do you just go and talk to your
customers i went to an office one time
you know these companies that they do
the trashes they recycle what do you
call those companies
something landfills or something what is
the name of it there's a name of it no
it's actually a big it's a multi-billion
dollar company
that recycles papers we have them
ourselves i don't know the company we
have a big contract with them
anyways so i go into the office and
the the vice president of that office
invites me in and i'm speaking to their
guys and can you talk my sales because
i'm trying to figure out a way to
improve my sales guys i said great
so i set up and i said okay out of your
calls at you how many calls you make per
week they give me the number i said how
many dinner to existing customers how
many are to new customers oh 95 percent
okay 95 to new customers right oh no no
no
no 95 to existing customers so there's
your problem so we don't even need to go
anywhere else
speech over how long you've been in
sales 20 years how long you been here 15
years
how long have you guys been flat in this
office about nine years we don't call it
flat we just say
call it consistent i said i'm sorry i
call it flat in the world of business
you're either grown or you're down you
guys are dying just everybody knows this
i said
how come you guys don't knock on doors
or go talk to businesses that are not
customers of yours
you ain't growing your business you're
just rehashing the same exact customers
and by the way you're eventually going
to lose customers to somebody else
that's not bring them in
baptize them later i'm in the game of
converting
i'm in the game of getting people who
are not believers of business to say
babe maybe we start a business part-time
i'm in the game of getting people to say
uh you know like yesterday gray came in
here he said the most interesting thing
the guy that we wrote a book together
with
phenomenal thing he got emotional he's
here yesterday he had he we had a very
special moment he says you know what's
crazy pat
i said what's that he says you know what
was the toughest thing about writing
this book with you because he's my
writer he wrote the book we're not
co-authors he's a writer he wrote so
rather than getting a ghostwriter and
said i wrote this book i don't write
this book we wrote it together but he's
my writer right okay
he says cause he saw me intentionally i
said before you write this book you have
to see me at the best of my worst
he says what do you mean i want you to
be in my board meetings and see how i
react
i said i want you to see me in sales
meetings and see how i react he says you
can go in the most exclusive meetings
that nobody else is invited
then you can write the book so he saw me
everywhere he saw him he was with me
with kobe with
bush with back end i'm upset things are
not working out i'm in my suite
that's caesar he's everywhere seeing me
at my
best worst ticked off losing it this
didn't work out just lost couple hundred
he's seen everything
right i said now you can write the book
then we write the book together
you know what he said yesterday was so
moving he says pat you know
i'm the professor i'm the guy that's the
consultant
i'm the one that tells people what to do
he says the hardest thing about writing
the book with you
is you force me to get in the arena he
said i have not been in the arena for
15-20 years
see that to me is winning because i
converted someone to get into the arena
you win when you convert you don't win
when you're talking to the same people
that say uh-huh and did you see
these guys don't care about us you are
not winning
you win when you convert the left won
because they converted
the right loss because they stop
converting and paying attention to the
people who are younger in social media
you lost that's a strategic loss
what did i vote for you think i'm voting
to raise the taxes
no you think i'm voting for i got an
email yesterday from my friends at
goldman sachs there's a very high
likelihood taxer going up
i've known this you think we voted for
that we want to put the money back into
the business
no we don't vote for raising taxes we
don't vote for
you know hey let's go pay off everyone's
college we don't vote for that stuff
we vote for free enterprise free market
i don't care who the person is
i don't even want to see the face of
trump on biden give me your policies
i'll tell you who i'm voting for
that's who we vote for then it didn't
work out why didn't it work out
it's strategy so there there is a very
very big misconception and a mindset
by the way christians i want to spoke to
a group of pastors in newport beach
and they invited me can you come and
talk to these pastors i said hey
uh why has donations have gone down
not to your church to christian churches
why are christian churches so empty
why why why is it well it's because the
new generation you know they just don't
want to tie it and they don't understand
that the bible ah no no no no don't get
technical
don't blame the new generation because
you walked up two hills when you're
going to school and it was snow you know
all those stories that we always hear
about
why has it well you know all these
things i heard i said can i tell you the
truth what i said
mormon church is killing it
same generation why is the mormonism
killing it i said you ever gone to
mormon's
uh uh youtube channel yeah have you can
you go to lds's youtube channel
no but i pulled it i said let's go no no
i said listen i'm not telling you go
become a mormon
i'm telling you during the same time
that you're losing members and donators
mormonism's killing it how many
subscribers does lds have just type in
lds and go to channel
1.63 million subscribers a
a religion lds has 1.63
you you go look at the lds church why
have they they have a system
they're young look at their videos go go
to
uh fil sort by go to sort by on the top
right look at it
14 million view okay 12 million view
nine and a half million i'm a child of
god i'm
okay how come christians are in churches
are not growing up
i go to a church in dallas i'm not gonna
say the name i go to a church in dallas
it's a big church
fits 5 000 people 600 people are there
75 year old pastor is preaching it's
time to be a mentor
let a young guy come in and do it you
preach maybe once a month yeah
but no still have to have control so
again but you're not converting mr
pastor
but i know everything about the bible or
not it doesn't matter the idea of
christianity is to go disciple
it's the cost of disciples when you
become a christian the first book they
ask you to read is the cause of
discipleship depending on what church
you go to
cost of discipleship is what what
happens to be a disciple
because the whole idea of becoming a
christian is to what to convert
the idea of business is what to convert
to somebody to say i believe in you
steve jobs
let's go change the world i believe in
you elon musk let's go change the world
don't make don't ask any question just
get on the damn what the jet the plane
don't question anything let's just go
right okay people have forgotten
that politics business religion
family anything you look at is all about
converting
and whoever's converting is winning and
whoever just wants to talk to people
that agree with them
you are not losing you're going to get
your ass handed to you in ways you've
never been handed to before and the
separation of the
the competitor is not going to be small
it's going to be a wide
wide distance separation between you and
your competitors and it's not going to
be pretty that's what's going on today
with politics yeah
very interesting by the way were they
happy they invited you over at the waste
management place to give that speech did
they thank you
did they pay you they never see this
this thing with me because i don't need
the money like i'm not a motivational
speaker i go there because i like
problems i like to see
what can we do i never got invited back
do you know what happened to them
the main guy got fired yeah the main guy
that's sitting there quietly behind
closed doors nobody knows who he is
making 200 grand you get fired
you know extremism to me is just so
unattractive these days we've we've
dealt with it to such a degree through
that political cycle and through
last fall and everything i just people
need a break from it it's not working
it's not great it's not good for this
country i'll give you an example
last night i i put um jimmy kimmel on or
no uh jimmy fallon on for five minutes
just to see
i wanted to just get a gauge what are
talk shows like because i never watch
them
you know because they became so
political i mean stephen colbert is
literally a
political show and i turned it on and it
was a repeat from right before the super
bowl and him and quest love and one of
his other
roots band members were doing a contest
to see who could make the best
dip for the super bowl it was a
hilarious bit and i'm going
this is so refreshing i mean this is
just these guys they're in the studio
right there's an audience a small
audience but they're clapping
people want to get away from the
extremes on extremism that's why i said
i don't think
these hardcore mega followers are going
to be there
for a parlor because there's no one
there that's
leading them and that they're just
blindly following because he's saying
what you want to hear
i don't i don't agree with that that
that i don't agree with
i think i think mega crowd is mega crowd
i i don't think they're
trump yesterday for president's day just
got out to spend some time with
people here in mar-a-lago he drove
around and people were going crazy here
and
but that's because it's him he was out
there they're not out there just i get
that okay
what i what i'm what i'm saying with
this is you know what i'm saying with
this is
trump okay so my message isn't directed
to mega people
it's not my message isn't even directed
to trump
my message is you had a candidate like
trump
he pushed the envelope yes the twitter
stuff out of control should have been
controlled look at biden it's so quiet
nothing's going on like that's
you said something said it's so much
peace or climate today right
okay but the mega crowd had somebody to
buy into
okay what did trump do trump went and
converted people
trump converted people you have to know
that trump is a converter in 2016 he did
of course in 2017-2020 no no
trump is one of the greatest converters
america's ever seen are you kidding me
like day one or like trump's gonna run
out of the 16 people who's at the top
he's at the bottom jeb bush was at the
top 140 million dollars
even huckabee was ahead of trump carson
was ahead of trump and
anybody that can get you to vote for
obama twice and then vote for trump
you're converting
you you're you're a converter you're a
converter
however however they realized
that they didn't have the right allies
and number two they realized the
republican party
didn't have the right tools like the
left does
the left controls all the tools they
didn't have all the tools this isn't
about that the mega crowd is going to go
away
50 years from now we're going to watch a
movie if we're still alive i'm going to
be 92 we'll still be alive because 50
years from now we're still going to be
alive apparently we're going to let's go
110 so so 50 20 years from now 30 years
from when we go to movies
and we watch the movie of what happened
the last four five six years with trump
you're gonna be like i cannot believe i
lived through that that's what you're
gonna say yeah i cannot
live through that totally but he is
still going
to have loyal followers 10
20 30 40 years from now this is not
going away
if i sat down with trump and i did an
interview it'd be a very different kind
of an interview
very very different kind of an interview
very it'd be a very different kind of an
interview because
you know my opinion he's at a point
right now that's a very challenging
place to be
okay because look
when you do case studies what's the
benefit of reading case studies when you
go to mba school what is the only
benefit of going to mba
making those mistakes yeah you learn
from other companies when you look at
case studies
what is the best case study that trump
should study what is the best case study
that trump should look at
what's the best case study what what
what family
what family kennedy okay kennedy
what is the case study of kennedy's
family well you got the the
joe the guy that started it all right
who was in politics
raising kids to follow him and okay you
know change the country
yeah telling his kids hey one of you
guys is going to grow up and be a
president which ones are going to be
where is sued at dinner luke shaw
he's mentally getting his kids to be
prepared to be a president right and
essentially
they were supposed to be presidents for
16 years
then the kids would have been presidents
that's the direction it was going
so then what happened who became the
sacrificial guy
well jfk got assassinated what happened
to the entire kennedy family
so so to trump right now if he wants if
he's a true believer and comes back and
you know says i'm going to come back in
2024 and does what he says he wants to
do if he does that
the same thing that happened to
kennedy's family could potentially
happen to the trump family
okay they're going to go after his
businesses they're going to have he's
going to be in court
between now and 2024. he got acquitted
which means he can run again in 2023.
jack dorsey said i don't care what
happens i'm not letting him back on
twitter no matter what happens right so
he's still going to have a different
platform to be able to
post stuff on you're not going to go in
parlor and be able to do much because
parlor is going to be all on one side
you need
neutral platforms to convert because
trump is
the ultimate converter agree or disagree
trump's a master converter the guy went
from being who he was to being a
billionaire to being on tv to be in all
that stuff to being a president you say
wait you became a tv guy yes what you
you you and from your dad was doing
rentals on the other side you want to
become
yeah the trump team is everywhere yeah
you wrote books about wall street
bestseller news
for yes you became a president yes you
got
what are you talking so he's at a point
right now that do i just
lay low to make sure my family can at
least have a peaceful life moving
forward
or do i say screwed guys we may have a
target from us from some of the most
powerful people in the world that
more more powerful than us but let's go
save this country it's going to be
interesting
but the mega audience is not going away
here's why i disagree with your
disciples
i'd love to hear it because trump is a
cult of personality that's what he is
he's got that charisma where people
would just follow him if he
decides i'm not going back into politics
it's not worth it
these people the mega followers are
going to feel betrayed
they're going to take it very personally
and they're not there is no more maga
then because they were there to follow
trump
and if he bails on them they'll bail too
and you look at the people that have
been arrested
you know that uh stormed the capital
right and remember
we were on the air the next day that
happened on a wednesday we did the
podcast on a thursday
and i said that day i guarantee you you
know they got about two weeks half these
people that got arrested are gonna ask
to get pardoned
right and a lot of them did but you know
you listen to him now and they all are
saying
i thought i was being led to do this i
thought he was telling us i mean i think
a lot of them feel betrayed
like he's stepped away percentage though
what percentage
i mean what percentage of the 74 million
fell but okay so first of all you know
the 74 million people that voted
what percentage voted because they
didn't vote for trump they voted
republican
what would you say you know i'm gonna
say a lot a big percentage okay
because i mean that would be me i mean i
was voting for the lower taxes and all
those things
so what percentage of the 74 million
voted republican not voted mega
okay i'm going to say you know 48 50 55
because i think a lot of the women the
suburban women that don't like trump
would still vote to
contact can you pull up the the record
of how many people
uh vote republicans every election like
how many total votes what would you say
adam
how many just vote republican regardless
paul what do you think what percentage
of the 74 million people that voted
voted republican not voted trump they
voted policies not for trump
80 okay so i i i uh uh
uh meaning their repo they're voting
republican regardless they're voting for
his
policies but they're saying this guy's a
little bit out of control on twitter
but i have to vote for his policy still
voting repo okay so 80
i think so so then that means out of the
74 million the 100
die hard mag of believers are what say
what's 20 of 74 million 15 million out
of the 15 million people how many of
them do you believe
are like dude you forced me to go to
capital that's what you did what
percentage of 15 million you think less
than one percent that's what i'm saying
i don't think that's the case i think
the case is
that uh it's not 74 million
mega i think it's 15 million meg i think
it's very important to differentiate
between those two
you understand what i'm saying it's not
so so it's not like if
we break down the map are you mega like
did you are you like die hard mega
no okay but you're republican you voted
that that way okay so
but you're not like going around saying
you know even though you said 33
a few podcasts ago so to me it's
principles it's
mega and then you know so i think it's a
market and i don't think that 15 million
is going away i i don't think that 15
million is going to go well okay if you
look
i don't think mag is going anywhere no i
don't think it's going away and i don't
think trump is going anywhere either
i think he's such a do you think he runs
2024. oh yeah i do
you think he wants 2024. i do not i do
not think he's going to run such an
egomaniac
is he going to run 2024
okay i i actually do you know he's
coming back i think it's going to be an
ugly situation
trump if we've learned anything from
trump he's not the type of person to be
like
well guys we had a good shot thanks
everybody the day of the insurrection
the day that they were trying to hang
mike pence he was not
calling in the military he did nothing
to stop that
nothing so if we've learned anything
from trump he ain't backing down from
anything he's going to double triple
quadruple down
there's one there's one thing i don't
want to see i don't want to see on the
debate stage
trump and pence i don't think that's
good for me i would love to see that
yeah i don't either and here's the other
thing if trump runs again he destroys
all his businesses and the legacy he
built with the brand
i i think it's done and his kids are in
serious danger too if he runs again and
i think he'll put his family above it
why would he be in serious danger if he
ran well the the the brand is already
extremely tarnished
if he gets in again it'll be dissolved i
mean there's no one with
i mean outside that fringe element but
how about this
i think he's going to run again in 2024
straight up does he run
does he have penalty i think he's
running republican maga
not independent no that's my opinion
does he have a shot in 2024 if he's
going against a
joe biden even a kamala or even a
uh i mean a lot of that it's so early to
even tell because it's just
he's just been president for one month
biden so we don't know how things are
going to if it opens up say
say things open up and market go dow
goes to 40.
okay if dow goes to 40 market opens up
biden's able to influence powell to go
one more year at zero percent interest
rate and we have this fake economy
and he gets real and it's going to be
tough to it's
you know most people want to vote for
the same president most people don't
want to historically we like two terms
we don't like one terms
right okay so you have to you have to
keep that part in mind as well you do
pretty damn bad if you're going to only
go one term
or it has to be a massive crisis like
a kobet coming in with a world shuts
down or a third-party candidate like
ross perrault
in 92. george bush you're right so there
has to be a
you know a black what do they call it a
uh what's the
black swan it has to be some and and
this covert is a black swan like
if there's no kovit what's the
percentage
yeah i mean so you have to realize kobe
kind of threw him out so
i think if there's not if the dow's at
40 he extends the interest rates for one
more percent
one more year and it's pretty peaceful
things have opened up restaurants
everybody's up they're going
okay let's just go one more year yeah a
long way to go one month out of what 48.
exactly yeah we got something
to your point you brought up the uh the
situation where
uh the overall sentiment of the country
feels a little more mellow now a lot
less stressed
you know i threw it out there given the
given the situation at hand i threw it
out there's a question does does there
seem to be less tension
less stress does the country seem to be
a little less on edge
and i'm just gonna say yeah i mean i i
feel it for real in california
um it does feel different and i don't
think it's a rally behind biden
and it certainly has nothing to do with
newsome you know our governor who
hopefully we get out here in a few
months
i i think it's the byproduct of this
there's less
bickering every day this insane thing
that we were going through for months
and months i think it feels differently
walking around i think um you know if
there was any political motivation
behind the shutdowns of what was going
on they're easing up a little bit like
where i live
the restaurants are open again down or
outside i mean those these little
freedoms you take
you know that you used to take for
granted are now a huge deal to be able
to go sit somewhere
go to a gym these are huge things and i
do think that
the collective mood of the country is
better over the last month i think i
agree i just think
the the word that comes to mind when i
think of trump in the last four years
and it served him well in some cases and
it served him not well in other cases is
frenzy it was always a friend the news
of the day and trump tweeted this
and here's who he's fighting with and
here's what he said about this and trump
did this
it's just so frenzied and you know every
day
i mean he would always you know control
the media control the narrative friends
and friends you're like
i'm good with sleepy joe just kind of
keeping it cool and just
go be sleepy joe we've had a very
frenzied four years
just get back to basics just do the work
it doesn't need to be a rock star
you don't need to be uh you know a
personality just
freaking makes politicians work it's so
weird how we are as voters
you know we go from on obama oh he's a
socialist he's this to we go to a trump
oh he's so you know he's so good oh
always non-stop talking like can't you
just be quiet we go to a guy that never
wants to come out and he's just quiet
yeah we are so radical sometimes let me
let me hear let me say something and
this is that i
recognize this and i say this every time
that they talk about politics this
is if you want to know politics in this
country it's a pendulum
we're all the way here it's like an oval
no not an oval
it's like a half circle marriage is like
an oval where's that movie what movie is
that
uh harry and uh what is uh adam
no no it's the adam sandler movie i now
pronounce you doug and larry yeah
duggan or something like that yeah it's
like an old chuck and larry chuck and
larry chuck and larry's what it is
whatever but a pendulum think about it
you know even the last 20 years
you go from reagan yeah right all the
way to the right or conservative
you know bush four years boom clinton
clinton
eight years boom right after that
pendulum go back to bush
from bush you go to obama yeah but you
know what this is like
just keep going i don't think that's it
i'll give you a different analogy if you
want to do analogies i'll give you
this is like the guy that's like listen
man this last girl i tated
i i just want somebody that's a little
bit calmer
i want her to be calm like this is too
much like she's like yeah and they go
day to come dude
i'm so bored outside you know once again
and they're like and then i watched
cocktails the other day
and he's telling the uh uh what he
called it the you know
his uh buddy coughlin's law the guy
whoever that guy is
yeah he says he says you know you
you can never land a billionaire you
can't he he's teasing him so he goes and
gets the billionaire
the girl in the corner so he's going to
her place and one of the days he wakes
up and she's like
ah and two and three and he said and he
says
every day at five o'clock in the morning
like he's struck dude
you wanted the girl now you got it so i
just want a family girl
so america can't make it we're bipolar
it's an understatement you know over the
last month i've literally
you know for vt post i'm going there
seems to be better stories to cover
better stories to choose and i'm going
why is that
have more interesting people just come
to the forefront but but here's what it
is
trump is such an oxygen suck you know he
absorbs
everything from both sides both sides
are obsessed with him the left side
hates him so much
that's all they can do is talk about him
and react to him same thing with the
right he dominates
everything every news cycle hollywood
changed because of him every industry
essentially
changed because of the feeling he just
sucks all the energy out of a room
right now there's other things to talk
about you're hearing more about some
business stories and they understand i
think hollywood might go back to being a
little bit more hollywood
i use the analogy of watching jimmy
fallon last night it felt like a
different
show compared to what he aired the last
two years so it's
i think it he is such uh and you know
just an
outlier as far as the personality of him
and what he brings to the table i think
it's better for the country
if he probably just says i had my run
and i'm good well other other stories
are getting some data by the way if you
think again we may have a different
crowd because they're going crazy right
now i'm furious with you guys if you
think he's gonna run again
put thumbs up if you think there's no
way in the world he's gonna run in 2024
push thumbs down i'm curious to know
what people are going to say and if you
enjoy the dialogue and your first time
here with us smash that subscribe button
help us get 200 000 subscribers so
let's talk about spanx what is a spec
what is a spec
a special purpose acquisition company
which
to simplify what a spec is it's
essentially
going public without having to spend
the four to 10 million bucks of going
public and waiting 18 months to go
public it's somebody that already has a
holding company on the market
with some cash in it and the stocks
around 10 some of them are 10
and 50 cents because they got a warrant
on a back end and you go and say hey
let's do something with the spec
couple months later you're on the market
with a ticker okay so that's a spec to
simplify but
let me read a few things here for you
roger lee of battery venture says that
spec used to be a bad four-letter award
in silicon valley now the board of every
high-profile startup is discussing
spec as a legitimate way to go public
according to jeff crowe of norwest
venture pardon the sudden burst of specs
reminds some long-timers of the dot-com
bubble in the late 1990s pre-revenue
businesses with far out goals are going
public at astronomical valuations and
famous athletes and other celebrities
are getting in the mix
the wall street skeptics uh it looks uh
like the finance industry's latest
scheme to make money
speculators etc etc right 44 billion
dollars so far and 144
deals according to spec insider but the
following names have gone into the spac
movement shemat who's a potential
governor in california
serena williams steph curry shaq alex
rodriguez billy bean tillman frittata
billy
there is a lot kaepernick just got it
there's a lot of people that are going
into the spac market and silicon valley
saying maybe
this is the way to go because people
don't want to wait that long
thoughts on specs let me tell you
something i
quite candidly never heard of a spec
until like last time for a while i
thought it was a super political action
committee
you know you have a pack i thought it
was a spa oh you got it back
that's literally what i thought it was
for a while
that's true because they do call it
super pac but i don't know if it's just
because i've been
you know following chamath's interviews
a little bit more lately
and he's quote unquote the king of the
spec but it's starting to pop up more
and i've caught into here i've heard it
and you know i'm
covering a little bit on the finance
stuff and valuetainment economics and
and finally yesterday i was like pat we
were kind of brainstorming ideas i'm
like
what's up with all these spack talk not
smack talk
not you know now we're doing here and
you're like you were like intrigued you
were almost like thrown off like well
what do you know about back what do you
what so we do you were just like who
told you about spec
it's just been popping up a lot more
lately so give the the audience what
they want give them that
spac talk to them what's the point here
you just have to keep in mind spec is
you saving time and money from going
public
that's what especially competition to an
ipo yeah different speed
speed to market just think about speed
to
market if it if a regular if you ride on
the run a company you're doing 50
million a year 100 million
200 million whatever you're doing he
said guys i want to go public
okay good for you lawyers galore
accountants ridiculous going through a
goldman or somebody that's going to say
we're going to take a five percent fee
or ten percent
fee or six they're gonna take that as
well because when they take you public
they're calling their clients so they're
taking a fee
for helping you raise capital and take
12 to 18 months
versus somebody comes and says look i'm
already public why don't you put your
company in my spec
and then at the same time i can help you
be public in the next you know
30 to 90 days so it's speed to market
but what doesn't happen is the following
what where spec doesn't work is the
following
there are a lot of spacks that get a bad
reputation because there is no company
it's not a company it's an idea so there
is no
proof of revenues there's no proof it's
just here's the idea that we have and
here's what we're going to do and let's
go on the market and we think this idea
is going to blow up and be a
multi-billion dollar company
and the market's like but what do you
have so far when then
when the market comes in and does the
investigation like dude these guys have
nothing going on
those are the specs that take about and
there's a lot of specs that people are
going out without a real business
you have to be very careful of that but
traditionally you got a real business
you're doing well for yourself you got a
transportation company guys doing a 120
million year you're netting 10 15
million dollars you're like okay
let's go take a look at being a spec
yeah you've got a real business going on
interesting do are they bringing in the
big name athletes just for the name
factor and recruiting factor
and just uh credibility is that why
you're seeing these guys
you you got to realize back so so spax
so imagine
you go out in a spec and you're a half a
billion auto company
the guy that owns the spac currently the
holding company
that guy ends up taking somewhere
between you know 15 to 20 percent of
shares so if you got 15
to help you go public that's essentially
the cost it would have been anyways if
you waited 18 to 20 you know fees and
everything yeah
so he takes 15 so you go public they say
okay we'll let your company be part of
our spec
half a billion dollars the hopes is a
year later for that company to be
worthwhile
you know uh a billion dollars if it's
worth a billion dollars
that guy officially doubled his 100
million to 200 million made 100 million
dollars okay then he liquidates 50
of that then he liquidates 25 of that
etc etc so there's a lot of
opportunities and by the way for some
people like i don't want to put my money
into spec
most people that go into spec a company
that goes on a spec the ceo the guy at
the top the executives cannot sell their
shares
they have to stay on so it's not like
hey i'm in got the money i'm out there's
a timeline
because they're watching you so
regulators are watching you so yes it's
actually a very
uh interesting thing that's creating
it's been around for a long time
but today a lot of people since things
are moving quickly
are very much interested in specs some
of the terminology you hear
always thrown around with spak you
always hear blank check
companies why are these why is it
considered a
blank check company because there's no
there's no company in it it's just money
it's a holding company with money in it
it's a whole
that's a good way of putting it okay yes
it's a shell company okay
speaking of ipos you want to talk about
bumble you want to talk about that or
bitcoin with jp morgan morgan stanley
let's go let's go to
bumble founder whitney wolfhard becomes
a younger self self-made woman
billionaire after i appeal bumble
founder
uh is now worth uh one and a half
billion dollars at 31 years old
she's also the youngest chief executive
to take a company public in america
female co-founded a company about seven
years ago in order to reinvent the
dating app structure the app
unlike its competitors gives women the
ability to control the conversation
it is the only dating app where women
make the first move however her journey
into the digital dating scene didn't
start with bumble
in fact prior to her start with the
multi-billion dollar company she
co-founded the biggest competitor
tinder wolf heard left hinder and filed
a lawsuit against the company alleging
sexual harassment
tinder denied any wrongdoing and the
suit was eventually settled shortly
after in 2014 she founded bumble bumble
also owns the dating app badou
together the apps are used in 150
countries with tens of millions of
monthly subscribers
thoughts it's so fascinating i mean
she's a rock star she's unbelievable to
think that she
helped create tinder and you think of
the perception of tinder is there a more
creepy
dating app out there clearly i'm not an
expert on dating apps but that just
seems to me
as being creepy it'd be like you started
penthouse and then you quit and then you
started national geographic i mean going
to what she did
with bumble but she's brilliant she's
worth 1.5 billion you know she sued them
on her way out and got a million dollars
because she was dating the four
the other co-founder of tinder and she
sued him for sexual harassment he
allegedly called her a [ __ ] and a gold
digger and things like that so she got
out
with vengeance she went out to create
their competition
and destroy them i mean that was
literally her philosophy and she did it
mission accomplished it's unbelievable i
learned about bumble through my barber
all right young guy probably at 26 good
looking dude he go hey
tz i'm on bumble man it's on what is
that and he's telling me about
he's pulling out his phone showing me
all the girls that make the first move
he had two serious relationships and i
think he might get engaged now
to the one that he's been dating she's
beautiful he's got to get two of them no
no he had
he had a relationship that's impressive
i mean it's unbelievable he's going for
his third it's incredible
is he armenian he's just
he loves women no uh no he's found a now
he's found someone that i think he's
gonna get engaged to
so it's it's great you know if she had
done the spec
accelerated this even sooner could she
would she have to give up more equity
is that part of the downside for a
company or for a founder like that that
you're giving up
more and you're and do the employees get
a little chunk of it because here's the
other thing that she did over the
weekend the new york post
got a hold of a slack message from her
that she sent out to the whole staff
they went public last week they killed
it you know it went up by
i don't even know the numbers i haven't
written down but it exploded in the next
two days
she sent a slack message out to
everybody and say hey
don't look at the stock price don't
think about the stock price
i think that's an unfair thing to say to
employees because if you were there to
help create that company
that is your end game the the stock
options that you have
how can you not i mean you know that
you're going to make me make mail
a few million so i i think that was
disingenuous i thought that was a bad
move for her to do that
now the other stat i have and it's
really unbelievable
is they only have 70 if full-time
employees
to build a company of that value with 70
i mean that is i mean find me a man
that's done that that's incredible
oh i'll find you a man all right right
on bubble um
a couple different things i've a never
done a dating app in my life and now
do we have a lie detector in the office
this is not good adam just listen
god's watching you right now just tell
the truth just tell the truth okay
guys match.com the first like this the
first app i've ever used is bumble i
just
recently started using it and the women
have to make the first move they're
pretty aggressive out there let me tell
you they're they're out there they
so have you been approached oh sorry
what happened what happened
tell us i haven't opened the app in a
few uh in a few minutes oh my gosh
700 messages
you've got like 12 full-time jobs what's
the approach what's been the best
approach ladies will will message you
and say
like things like hey sweetie hey
handsome i saw your profile hey buddy
you know not hey buddy but
you know for him it's just sweet and
handsome
that's tinder that's tinder i've never
done tinder but i might have to look
into that soon
um no for all the funny guys out there
never done grinder but
hey listen if you got enough money
what's up he keeps bringing up the apps
he hasn't done i mean i think that's
saying something
but um something uh someone pointed this
out i would love to give
whitney wolf heard credit
you know youngest female billionaire
like obviously everything that's going
on i would love to give her credit for
that
you pointed out well kylie jenner
actually was the youngest
self-made billionaire but she didn't go
public but then you find out whitney
wolf heard
who's who's heard who's that guy
who's her husband well it turns out
michael heard is like an oil
tycoon in from texas our old stomping
grounds
and believe me he had some
positive influence in the in the
framework of this company so it wasn't
like
some you know lowly girl started a
dating app and made it
like to the big leagues she had a
billionaire buddy husband
that you know that i don't know if she
met him on a dating app or not but
then how old is her husband do you know
is he a lot older
no okay similar adam also she started
uh the company in 2014 and they didn't
get married till 17. i mean they might
have met
before but it seems like what's your
shot listen are you like
are you trying to get a free bumble
account what are you trying to do man
you look bad just state the truth what's
your what's your favorite
following honestly what's my profile
yeah i'm bumble
what like what do you mean what is the
name but it's just kylo ren if they
wanted to find you
really they can't they can't search it
though the norwegian style cannot
why how do you so you can't search the
name on bumble no it's it's
it's based off location oh okay so you
have to be a location okay
i'm soy boy everywhere oh three uh 50
states i'm everywhere
just find me ladies on the soyboy mafia
channel is there anything else to say
about this or that's
in bumble one thing i was waiting like
it changed my life no it
has not changed my life yet yet one
thing i will say i've
i've done my due diligence you know i'm
literally ocd methodical i say
you know i i asked a couple of my dating
gurus who were you in high school what's
up what's up and
without a doubt everyone's like hinge
and bumble that's where you got to go
hinge and bumble that's where it's
hinged hinge h-i-n-g-e
not a good name for a dating side really
hinged hinged
no it's not hinged hinges
you're using the app wrong bro take my
car if you need to okay
but kai has kai have you not met a girl
on bumble
no actually what that what are you doing
so you know your speaker's off yeah
kai what app do you because you've done
you've done some you've done some more
i've used more hinge
okay there it is got it well if you're
looking for a hot norwegian man ladies
hinge up kai loot it first of all good
for her that's all i can say
good for her for you know doing what she
did tinder and the
change one little thing you were talking
about girl approaches
you approaching them you know changes a
little bit and uh got a market for it
where it's a little bit more where the
guy's there and if you're approachable
then they'll approach you and you have a
you know somewhere to take in
you know what let's pull up bubba right
now let's see what we got
can you imagine you read a message and
you make fun of the girl and ends up
becoming your wife one day i would love
that story there we go we got bumble
here it is
it's yellow yellow for like a bumble bee
he's a premium member by the way who's
this
sock what's up who's this who's this wow
so what you do is you say all right
what's this girl's name
all right we'll go to the right you
matched she had already requested me
she had already requested me there it is
all right keep swiping
i don't know see this is a two girls in
the picture which one of my
two girls in the same picture i'm
telling you that's not bumble listen
you're not on bumble
i'm on bumble that's gr
[Laughter]
pandemic this girl put a picture of like
her hot friend with her dating's just a
whole different world
turns out it's not so you got to go left
on that one this girl's got a far-off
bikini pic
you got to get closer that's an honor
guys for you yeah
the point is there's there's a lot of
dudes we got to finish this podcast so
you can go message all right i'm going
to be on bubble for the next hour
you need an assistant to manage that
whole thing pat we've been talking about
that what's crazy is i
i i was never around single during the
app era
yeah yeah so i have no clue but
i have plenty of people around me who
are using the greek god
uh that would have been the name greek
god
your birthday's october sort of ten ten
sixteen
eighteen close yeah greek god 1018
message pbd
okay so listen if uh if you're on bumble
i guess this was uh
the advertisement for uh adam today's uh
message is a sponsor these podcasts are
sponsored by adam sosnick's
bumble account you can find them in boca
raton adam
sosnick he is single
and uh he's looking very good with
finances healthy works out where it's
very short shorts and
uh athletic i don't know what else to
say knows how to do different accents
he's funny he's comedic yeah he can do
jewish accent no problem he can do
german russian i mean
extremely talented thank you i
appreciate extremely talented so that
was an endorsement
right there there it is can you put that
on my bumbo profile
wow uh so are we scheduled for
thursday we are scheduled for thursday
same time
8 a.m we're scheduled to do the podcast
thursday are you in town or
okay so thursday so here's what's gonna
happen thursday i'm not gonna be on a
podcast on thursday it's gonna be you
adam and kai doing the podcast on
thursday i won't be here but we're still
on
doing a podcast i'll be back next week
this week i'm gonna be in
i gotta fly to louisville then i gotta
fly to uh
dallas then i gotta fly to hawaii that's
going on this is a very very
busy week with the with the weather
right now i wish everybody traveling to
you and obviously you first and foremost
but everybody traveling
just be safe out there yeah and if you
have wi-fi on your plane
message uh adam on okay hey gang if you
enjoyed this smash that subscribe button
we'll do it again thursday take care
everybody bye bye bye bye
you